c'est une belle affiche ils sont le pen
il regarde moi elle joue avec ses
papiers comme il est en train de le
faire en ce moment
elle regarde ailleurs parce qu'elle a
peur mais aurait bien raison n'est pas
vrai candidat monsieur ne peut pas
débattre avec moi la voiture balai de
monsieur hollande
vous m'avez traité de semis démente de
sa vocation de moitié il souffrait
beaucoup monsieur mélenchon notamment un
des critiques qui sont faites aux
politiques et pourtant qu'est ce que
vous les méritez un parce que qui a
contribué à faire croire aux français
que l'intégralité des hommes politiques
étaient malhonnêtes
c'est vous et c'est vous parce que vous
parce que moi parce que mais oui bien
sûr marty mais qui à lui seul la caisse
claire hédon part de rabat dont paris le
chef monsieur marine le pen un peu de
calme finalement nous avons du temps
doux mois les puristes kitsch hot comme
ça à ses missions du pas où pierrick m'a
excité rennes a fait un faux tracts
je trouve ça quand même assez pathétique
il n'y aura jamais une faille entre nous
pour vous mettre la pile est méritée
alors madame quand vous dites du bien je
peux en parler et c'est un vieil article
visiter tout jeune là dessus le seul
parti qui réhabilite la politique c'est
le front national
je ne connais pas madame le pen elle ne
me connaît pas nous affrontons sur le
plan des idées il y à une grandeur et
une noblesse à s'affronter
voilà
[Musique]